good morning Hank it's January 10 2012
the day that The Fault in Our Stars
comes out it's actually Monday January
9th but I have to make this video now
because the more I got to be doing a
bunch of things it's what to do is date
the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters how you doing
good I'm just a tiny bit stressed out
not to leave my family for a month which
is kind of a bummer but I'm excited to
go on door how are you doing you can't
answer you're inside of the camera I
hope I get my copy today so I can lick
your signature um that's not a question
but I don't recommend licking Sharpie
that that's bad for you so what inspired
you to write The Fault in Our Stars
almost twelve years ago I worked as a
student chaplain at a children's
hospital ever since then I've been
trying to write a funny honest story
about it and it just you know took a
while long while do you think The Fault
in Our Stars is your best book yet I
don't know the reviews have definitely
been better than for any of my other
books but authors shouldn't be trusted
to judge their own work I don't think
like Mark Twain thought that his best
book was Joan of Arc ya know Hank I
gotta go pack and stuff walk with me
could an unladen swallow carry a copy of
The Fault in Our Stars in its talons
well definitionally not as it would then
be a waitin swallow do you like this tie
was it hard to write The Fault in Our
Stars as a parent I don't think I could
read it until I was a parent how much
research did you have to do about the
medical stuff in The Fault in Our Stars
more than a hypochondriac probably
should what made you decide rate this
one from a girl's point of view that's
pretty hard answer without spoilers but
part of it was that I wanted to think
about the way gender constructions shape
our understanding of what constitutes
heroism do you think Beiber Vendetta is
a proponent of democracy or anarchy
I think beaver vendetta is primarily a
proponent of a very specific and
pervasive idea of heroism will you do
peanut butter face I'm in an airport
people think that I'm crazy alright fine
hold on yes have a peanut butter
crackers these are the best I could do
happy well I feel out of the loop if I
haven't read Looking for Alaska no it's
not like Harry Potter my books don't
have anything to do with each other what
genre of music are the hectic Glo the
genre of awesome hey my pre-order wasn't
signed don't panic just email sparks
laughs at gmail com with your name
address and the place where you ordered
the book did you ever get emotional
while writing this book yeah quite a bit
actually but I'm a crier wait is the
Faulkner stars gonna make me cry or
laugh or what well ideally it's going to
make you feel all of the things people
in the airport think that I'm crazy the
people in the airport think that I'm
crazy I probably should have done that
while doing a dance that's probably
let's face it there's nobody in the
airport seriously I got this whole
section to myself there were some people
here but they left when I started
walking into a video camera was esther
an inspiration for this book definitely
there's no way I could have ever written
The Fault in Our Stars unless I'd known
Esther but at the same time it's really
important to note that hazel is not
Esther the book is made up I wrote a
novel I promise
does The Fault in Our Stars contain
anything about fruit I don't think so I
think that might be one of its
insufficiencies is a failure to tackle
fruit
are there any tickets left to anywhere
on the tour to nerdfighting yeah if you
live near New Orleans Houston Austin
Phoenix Albuquerque Seattle or San
Francisco otherwise no I'm sorry
take it info in the doobly-doo is this
real life
has nerdfighteria influenced your
writing at all as you're probably seeing
meeting a nerdfighteria has shaped this
book in so many ways that I can't even
list them what was your favorite moment
in the creation of The Fault in Our
Stars so Hank Islamic mystics have this
word Phenom which means like dissolution
or annihilation of the self and for me
that's what reading and writing do when
they're working and when I was writing
The Fault in Our Stars I was very very
lucky to have many moments where I felt
like I wasn't me like I was somehow
transcending the limits of myself and
that was really great and I can only
hope that readers will have that
experience - thank you all for being the
thoughts our stars I hope that you like
it
dftba best wishes Hank I will see you in
a minute when I go over to your room